la définition de la crise c'est que ça
repart comme avant
or la france que c'est une catastrophe
s'est pas inscrit il repartira j'espère
vous pensent mais pas comme avant il est
dans ce cas là on va voir qu'il y aura
des règlements de compte il y aura des
gens qui auront manifesté leur courage
et d'autres qui seront venus participer
à la diffusion du les rues à écouter
boris cyrulnik
les perspectives sont sombres on est
loin de la résilience cher à ce
neuropsychiatre
en revanche certaines voix comme celle
de l'archevêque de paris monseigneur aux
petits sont plus optimistes
le prélat voit dans la situation
actuelle en tous les cas c'est ce qu'il
dit au parisien un moyen de réhabiliter
la fraternité de réfléchir au sens de
l'existence bref de se ressaisir c'est
un avis que n'est pas loin de partager
le philosophe marcel gauchet qui dans un
long et interviews retrouvez sur figaro
vox s'exclame ah si cette crise pouvait
être l'occasion d'un vrai bilan et d'un
réveil que vivons nous dans les
commentaires que vous nous avez adressé
sur le figaro et sur leur facebook
vous n'êtes pas d'accord les uns parlent
de crise les autres parlent de
catastrophe
hélas il y a matière à débat amanda lee
[Musique]
alors crises ou catastrophes de ce côté
là les avis sont unanimes il n'y a pas
de débat
surtout quand on recourt à l'étymologie
grecque vous avez vu les rues vides de
calcutta comme à paris comme à new york
que c'est une expérience au sens strict
du mot ahurissante pour l'humanité ne
s'est jamais vu dans l'histoire le monde
est à l'arrêt ce qui vous arrive est une
catastrophe je pense qu'effectivement
c'est le meilleur mot pour qualifier cet
événement de la propagation de
l'épidémie et de notre incapacité à y
faire face
on est au delà l'uimm on parle de
catastrophe naturelle on parle de
catastrophe sanitaire au sens
étymologique y la catastrophe c'est un
bouleversement c'est un renversement le
virus n'est pas humain il est naturel il
dépasse l'humanité à tel point que
l'humanité est obligé de se confiner de
s'extraire de disparaître d'une certaine
façon pour laisser la catastrophe
s'estomper et c'est exactement ce que
vous estimez en majorité sur twitter si
selon rollin c'est d'abord une pandémie
jean-luc lui voient une remise en cause
de l'idéologie mondialiste
les progressistes vont en prendre un
sacré coup prédit-il
est ce votre avis en tous les cas on a
posé la question à nos débatteurs la
crise ducobu de 19 et un peu la fin d'un
monde
la fin de la mondialisation telle
qu'elle a été pensée par les néolibéraux
la fin d'un monde où la souveraineté
n'existe plus la faim d'amour de
l'état-nation s'étiole au profit d'
organisation supranationale
on voit bien que ça c'est fini des
principes sur lesquels est bien nous
vivons et qui peuvent être considérées
par certains comme étant des dogmes
d'où le fait qu'il puisse vivre cette
crise comme étant une remise en cause
profonde de leurs certitudes
ces grands principes révolutionnaires et
bien ce sont le rationalisme le
progressisme la différente isme
culturelle et morale la mondialisation
heureuse ou supposée heureuse avec le
monde sans frontières la division
internationale du travail
on voit bien que malgré l'extrême
sophistication de notre médecine de
notre technologie de toutes sortes
d'outils là on est confronté à quelque
chose qui me dépasse
on n'arrive pas à maîtriser et donc on
est dans cette parade up dans ce
paradoxe d'une ultra modernité mais qui
n'est pas suffisante bas pour pour
vaincre la mort quoi pour le dire tout
simplement c'est à dire que on est
rappelée à notre finitude à notre
fragilité à l'autre vulnérabilité
bernanos d'aisé les optimistes n'ont pas
pitié des sommes et de ce point de vue
là boris cyrulnik est très humain quand
il est inquiet pour l'avenir quand il
est inquiet pour la situation qui
sortira de cette catastrophe sur twitter
cet avis est partagé half prédit par
exemple une crise économique grave
une récession bref je le cite du sang et
des larmes nous allons vers une crise
puisqu'il y a eu un coup d'arrêt à notre
économie c'est ce que relève rôle a été
alors la situation va-t-elle être plus
mauvaise
doit-on s'attendre au pire là encore
débat et pourquoi pire est mauvais c'est
étonnant comme comme idée là où nous en
sommes c'est mauvais il est très
vraisemblable que nous allons connaître
un effondrement économique ou des
difficultés économiques ne crise sociale
j'ai évoqué l'arche de noé l'arche de
noé après le déluge
nous et sa famille les animaux qui
ressorte deux là vont re font d un monde
mouvant donc je crois qu on a aussi
cette idée en tête pendant qu'on est
dans cette espèce de temps suspendu
c'est une question de volonté je pense
qu'il faut pas être fataliste
qu'est ce qui va advenir et puis on
espère et puis on attend on est
attentiste et passifs c'est une question
de volonté à ce qu'on veut en faire
quelque chose est ce qu'on va en tirer
vers réellement des conséquences ou
est-ce qu'on va préféré retourner dans
un une forme de confort ou de deux
logiques procédural où on refait comme
on a fait ça dépend aussi de la volonté
évidemment politique des arbitrages qui
seront faits mais pour moi il n'y a pas
de fatalité si on veut en faire quelque
chose on en ferait quelque chose gémir
n'est rien agir c'est tout là aussi
c'est une citation de bernanos dans un
autre registre la revue esprit il y a
maintenant 12 ans en 2008 avait étudié
en profondeur ce concept cette notion de
catastrophe et l'avait comparée à la
notion au concept de crise et voici la
leçon thème lorrain buvant de l'epan à
cette époque à l'autre et si frappant
qu'on écrit ce numéro en 2008 c'est pas
parce que esprits et particulièrement
visionnaire c'est parce que 2008 c'était
une crise économique mais qui arrivait
derrière l'ouragan katrina aux états
unis le 11 septembre c'est comme si
depuis le début du 21e siècle en fait on
est tout le temps saisie par des
catastrophes
donc on est déjà entré dans une sorte de
pensée de la catastrophe d'où je crois
le succès de toutes les théories de
l'effondrement du collapse heures on en
a beaucoup parlé de ce moment le
collapse au logis est-ce qu'il était bon
brevets etc
ce qui est vrai c'est qu'on s'attendait
plutôt à un effondrement et écologique
ou climatiques et que là on est saisi
par un autre type d'effondrement avec
l'épidémie la pandémie alors maintenant
que votre le feu pas ce vers quoi
s'oriente ont là encore le débat est
ouvert
c'est très ambivalents si vous voulez
parce que on peut espérer que ça va être
une sorte de prise de conscience de
réveil collectif et que après tout ça on
vivra autrement peut-être dans un
rapport plus sage
à la science et à la technologie en même
temps que si vous regarder quelles ont
été les réactions à l'épidémie jusqu'ici
ce sont aussi des réactions hyper
technologique quoi peut penser en chine
le contrôle des populations les caméras
thermiques à l'entrée des métros les
drones pour prendre la température des
gens donc si c'est un peu à double face
ouest bien évidemment qu'il en
ressortira quelque chose de cette
expérience commune qui nous relient tous
avec nos différences il en sortira
quelque chose de différent encore une
fois c'est le sens originel du mot
catastrophe en grec
ça ne peut être qu'un bouleversement oui
il y aura nécessairement un
renouvellement des concessions à un
doublement des rapports de production
comme disait le vieux marx une nouvelle
manière de faire la politique est une
nouvelle manière de vivre en société
c'est une fils de régime qui se profile
puisque il vient ce qui va être discutée
ce sont des principes sur lesquels le
l'actuel régime repose alors qu'en
pensez vous partagez vous ces points de
vue en tout cas moi j'attends vos
analyses j'attends vos commentaires
il ya suffisamment de matière à débat en
tout cas à mon avis
[Musique]